millions of Americans are predicted to
take to the skies this holiday season
and even if you're not one of them you
know what I'm about to say is totally
true flying is the worst seats seem to
be getting smaller
flight attendants grumpier and delays
way more disruptive sure ticket prices
dropped in 2015 but complaints against
Airlines went up so why does flying suck
so much
well the airline industry was already in
decline since the 1970s but the 9/11
attacks the 2008 financial collapse and
rising oil prices made things worse it
got so bad that the US airline industry
lost a whopping 55 billion dollars
between 2001 and 2009
so airlines had to look for ways to cut
back one way was by slashing the number
of domestic flights over the last decade
mid-sized airports like ones in
Cincinnati or Albuquerque have seen the
biggest cuts so not only does this mean
less flight options for you as a
traveler but it makes delays and
cancellations more painful when you
don't have as many options to fall back
on but here's the thing even though
there's been a decline in domestic
flights there's been an increase in
seats
that means more passengers but less
space for you maybe you noticed it with
the legroom 20 years ago
you usually have 34 inches to stretch
your legs in economy class now some
airlines push 28 inches no wonder your
legs are hitting the seat in front of
you and then there's the extra fees
remember when checked bags cost nothing
well beginning in 2008 Airlines started
charging you for each bag and now those
fees make up billions of their revenue
more money for Airlines but more stress
for us because now more passengers tend
to bring carry-on bags to avoid those
fees which means more competition to
board the plane first to claim overhead
space so what are some airlines doing
charging for a priority boarding it's a
cycle of fees and if you think all of
this is annoying for you think about the
workers on some planes a flight
attendant with this smile is rare flight
attendants are often only paid when the
plane is physically in the
so no money for lay overs delays or
helping you with your heavy bag if you
get an overhead bin to begin with thanks
oh and the biggest shake-up in the last
decade mergers since 2010 major US
airlines have merged to form for
creating the ultimate airline oligarchy
that means 80 percent of all domestic US
travel happens on one of the four big
airlines so what does that mean for you
well consumer advocates are worried
about the drop in competition which
means airlines can collude to keep
prices high earlier this year the
Department of Justice even opened an
investigation to see if this is true but
ticket prices have gone down this year
and profits are back up for the four big
airlines this is partly due to lower
global oil prices but our cheap prices
enough for US consumers what can our
lines do to actually make us happy
travelers